sexy monsters tooth shattering action
and bearded dwarf ladies season two of
the witcher has it all yes it's been
almost two years since the release of
the witcher netflix series premiered and
after several kova delays season two has
just hit in this video we'll be going
over all the season's biggest unanswered
questions it's big cliffhanger ending
and theories for season three i've also
included a book spoiler section near the
end which goes over where some of the
story lines go in the books but i'll
warn you beforehand if you don't want to
be spoiled so pop a potion light your
swords aflame and make sure to like and
subscribe because here we go our story
begins shortly after the battle of
sadden which saw the defeat of the
encroaching nilfgaardian army by a group
of mages most notably yennefer of
wengerberg whose mastery of fire magic
helped turn the tide of battle but
yennefer has gone missing both geralt of
rivia and tesea searched for her amongst
the ashen aftermath believing her to be
dead but in reality she is held captive
by frangilla a sorceress who has joined
nilfgaard meanwhile geralt has joined up
with princess cirilla of cintra whose
entire family was slaughtered by
nilfgaard the two are destined to be
together through the law of surprise in
season 1 we saw how geralt invoked this
law after saving dooney archeon of
erlenwald a law which states the
receiver be given something you find at
home yet don't expect in this case it's
pavetta's child siri dooney does not
know that she is currently pregnant with
this child so from this point forward
destiny links geralt with siri through
the law of surprise of course geralt
doesn't believe in destiny destiny can
go
something which seems to change over the
course of season one but the real events
of season two unfold when frangilla and
yennefer are imprisoned by francesca
findebear queen of the elves of dull
blathana when francesca finds out both
of them have been receiving visions of a
similar cloaked figure she takes them to
these ancient ruins which contain the
tomb of voleth mare the deathless mother
a demon from another world who feeds off
the pain of others but none of them know
this yet this demon takes different
forms for each woman promising them that
which they want more than anything
francesca believes this entity to be the
elven prophet ethelene who predicted the
end of the world and arrival of the
destroyer who it's hinted is siri for
frangilla it's the nilfgaardian emperor
emir and for yennefer a mysterious young
girl named violet which jennifer
believes could be a quote young [ __ ]
up version of herself some have also
theorized it could be a manifestation of
the daughter she never had both
francesca and frangilla accept their
respective gifts from this demon
francesca wants a child there hasn't
been a pureblood elf in decades and if
the queen were to be with child it just
might be the hope her people need to
carry on the elves have been
discriminated against by humans for
centuries and now the northern kingdoms
have vowed to wipe them out frangilla on
the other hand wants to gain the favor
of the emperor she wants an army with
the elves having nowhere to go an
alliance orchestrated by frangilla to
have them fight alongside nilfgaard
would be a tremendous boon to her
political career then there's yennefer
who after the battle of sadden lost her
ability to control magic unlike
francesca and frangilla yennefer isn't
desperate enough yet to ask for her
powers back this will change over the
course of the season ultimately leading
yennefer to portray siri but more on
that in a bit by the end of the
penultimate episode volithmere's true
intentions are revealed while she does
give francesca and frangillo what they
desire it was all an elaborate plan to
farm a vast amount of pain so that she
could free herself from her enslavement
roughly 300 years ago the first witchers
imprisoned her but with enough pain to
feed on she can escape francesca's baby
is killed and frangilla's alliance with
the elves shattered this is enough pain
for volithmere to escape and inhabit the
body of siri you see volithmere is not
of this world and thus cannot take a
physical form she can only inhabit the
bodies of others this leads us to the
season's final episode where voleth has
trapped siri in a dreamlike state within
her own mind here siri is able to see
loved ones she's lost like mouse sack
and her grandmother queen kalente this
is all an attempt to keep her occupied
while the real world voleth is using
siri as a vessel to kill a vessel to
kill witchers as they sleep within the
halls of kharmorin the witcher's
training ground and home in episode 2
vessemer shows the dagger voleth used to
kill some of the earliest witchers
ironically it will be the same dagger
siri will use to kill well under
voleth's control yennefer follows geralt
back to caramorn apologizing for her
attempted betrayal of siri boleth had
promised her if she brought the girl to
the quote shattered black door she would
give her her powers back this plan
backfires when siri touches yennefer
breaking into her mind exposing
yennefer's conflicted feelings about
turning siri into this black door this
black door is the shattered monolith
siri broken season 1 and as istrit and
geralt learn in episode 5 they appear to
act as some sort of gateway to different
worlds while yennefer does at the last
minute tell siri not to go through this
store if she's afraid it's still a
massive betrayal to both siri and geralt
this sets her up for a chance at
redemption in the episode's final act
geralt eventually tracks down siri as
the bodies of several dead witchers are
found but he senses that something has
taken control of her and while she cuts
them and runs off we get a markedly
different introduction sequence showing
several spheres colliding into one
another creating stellosite the material
the monoliths are created from these go
on to create a tree which is fitting for
a number of reasons one the events of
the final episode transpire around the
medallion tree where the medallions of
fallen witchers hang second the episode
is titled family just like a family tree
metaphorically symbolizing the
relationship between these characters as
a makeshift family the sphere's
colliding hint at an event called the
conjunction of the spheres which
occurred 1500 years ago that brought
both creatures and humans to the world
known as the continent as we'll see in a
bit the show is definitely setting syria
up as a powerful force in linking the
continent with these other worlds
vesimir prepares to take down siri by
chugging a witcher elixir but geralt
doesn't want to lose her claiming that
if he can convince volthmir to leave her
body they can trap the demon once she's
out it's an interesting role reversal
with what happened to eskel in episode
2. eskel was also possessed but it was
geralt who wanted him dead and vesemir
who wanted to save him meanwhile
francesca continues to reel from the
death of her baby believing it was the
redanians who killed it out of hatred
for the elvish people rodinia is
currently ruled by king visimir the
second not to be confused with vesemir
and the head of rodanian intelligence is
sigismund dixtra who has a number of
spies across the continent including
philippa elhart who we find out has been
this owl he's been talking to the entire
season she is one of a few mages who is
able to polymorph meanwhile frangilla
informs kahir a nilfgaardian knight that
francesca and philavandrial have
ventured off to rodania to avenge the
death of their child frangilla is caught
off guard when she's congratulated for
her quote masterful plan it was the
birth of this child that caused
francesca to break the elvish alliance
with nilfgaard as the elves believed
their time was better spent rebuilding
than fighting wars however with the
death of this child the elves now have
reason to join the fight geralt
confronts voleth offering his own body
for her to take control of in exchange
for serious freedom but as the other
witchers prepare to do battle voleth
uses siri's scream the same scream that
broke the monolith outside syntra it
reveals that within the medallion tree
lies a similar stellosite monolith
meaning caremorin sits directly atop of
one of these gateways voleth opens a
portal allowing these basilisk type
creatures to attack and when vesimir
sees more dead witchers he knows siri
must be stopped even if it means killing
her but geralt blocks him still
believing she can be saved meanwhile in
her dream state siri meets her parents
she's never seen them before as they
died when she was just a baby voleth is
doing her best to keep syria entranced
while the fighting continues outside in
what is likely tretagor the capital of
dania francesca has gone on a killing
spree burning all the babies in the city
as retribution for the death of her
child this will undoubtedly cause a huge
war between the elves and rodania with
geralt occupied by an acid spitting
basilisk vesemir is able to stab siri
but voleth is too powerful being able to
heal the wound it's geralt who
ultimately figures out that because
voleth is not of this world she needs a
vessel of this world for her to live
meaning they can't lure voleth out on
her own only transfer her to a new host
this is where yennefer comes in offering
herself as this new vessel in an attempt
to right the wrongs of her betrayal she
cuts her wrists something that is
foreshadowed when yennefer originally
meets fulleth in episode 2. this
combined with siri's decision not to
live in this dreamlike state with her
parents allows her to snap out of it and
for the transfer to succeed interesting
fact siri's father is the only character
we see that doesn't disintegrate that's
because he's the only one who isn't
actually dead the big end of season
cliffhanger is that not only is he alive
but he is none other than the emperor
emir of nilfgaard up until now it was
believed her father dooney died along
with her mother pavetta in a sea storm
but there's a whole lot more story here
which will likely be covered in season
3. if you want to know what happens i'll
provide a brief rundown in the book
spoiler section at the end with bullets
successfully in yennefer's body geralt
asks siri to open a portal to volath's
world he believes that if siri can pull
monsters out of a monolith maybe she can
pull them back into it siri is able to
do this but the portal sucks her geralt
and yennefer to this strange land one
which siri saw in visions way back in
episode 3. gareth will later tell
vesamir he isn't sure where or what this
place is but it is inhabited by the
wraiths of morhog also known as the wild
hunt upon entering this world voleth
leaves yennefer's body and materializes
as eredin the leader of this hunt he
tells siri that her place is with him
but before she can be captured she ports
the three of them back to the continent
upon their arrival yennefer learns that
her powers are back using it to heal the
other witchers it's explained in a
one-off line that it was likely her
sacrifice that brought about this return
of power with siri back and more and
more people knowing that she is alive
and has elder blood everyone from
powerful rulers to the witch hunt will
be looking for her we learn that queen
kalente held a secret about her
bloodline that siri was a descendant of
lara doran an elven sorceress who fell
in love with a human mage this is likely
what inspired the tale nevillen told
suri about in episode 1. in episode 5
when tris marigold performs del durza on
siri allowing her to unlock genetic
memories we see a wounded lara
surrounded by fen and wed flowers the
same flowers vesimir found near siri's
blood which only grow where elder blood
has been spilled this is a genetic
memory of siri's ancestor who was killed
for falling in love with a human shortly
after the conjunction of the spheres
it's not just her elderblood that makes
her a wanted woman the brotherhood
composed of kings and mages want her so
that she could be married off to king
vizemir so they can have a rightful
claim to the sintra throne emperor emir
wants her because she's his daughter
although something tells me there's more
to it than that the elves also want siri
after estrid is caught he tells them
that siri is alive and that she is hen
ikea which is elven for elder blood and
according to the ethylene prophecy she
is the one to save the elven people
another interesting note is dixtra's
call for philippa to bring him back the
bard aka yaskir who had provided intel
to him in the past with yaskir's
proximity to both geralt and siri
nothing but trouble can come of this
geralt and yennefer also end the season
on complicated terms the dragon villain
tretinmirth said that destiny will bring
the two together but destiny alone is
not enough they need something more that
something more is siri yennefer is also
struggling with the fact that geralt
asked a wish of the gin in season one
that he'd never be apart from her so the
idea that her feelings for him is just
magic is always at the back of her mind
this is why when they first reunite this
season she tells him that she's still
hurt geralt is also hurt he's hurt from
her betrayal but regardless he wants her
to train siri as she has been the only
one so far who has been able to help her
with her powers and before we get into
the book spoilers we have the reveal
that emperor emir is siri's father not
only that but he was the one who had
francesca's baby killed in order to sway
the elves to join his cause and take up
arms against the northern kingdoms
because frangilla and kahir were
oblivious to this assassination they
told him that they were the ones to kill
the baby so he basically caught them in
a lie and has them arrested now here is
your book spoiler warning although a
reminder that the tv show and books can
easily deviate from one another so none
of this is confirmed as being a part of
season 3 or beyond the wild hunt wants
siri because of her blood believing that
if siri can provide an heir to their
king it will grant them access to travel
between worlds a power they used to have
but lost when they lost access to the
ard gate a large-scale portal which
allows for entire populations to move
across the multiverse by capturing siri
they believe it will fulfill ethelene's
prophecy providing an air that could
open quote forbidden doors then there's
reince the fire mage who teamed up with
lydia in search of siri he finally gets
to meet the person paying lydia for this
search we don't see who it is but in the
books it's vilgefortz we'll find out
he's been working alongside the emperor
helping him get the throne in exchange
for lands in the north once it's taken
over he believes that with siri's blood
he can claim her powers and he
definitely wants that then there's the
fate of kahir and franjilla because this
storyline diverted a bit differently
than it does in the books my guess is
that the emperor will set them free in
exchange for hunting down siri after all
it's kahir who is one of the few people
who actually knows what siri looks like
geralt and siri of course will be on the
run likely to find more info about the
wild hunt and how to stop them siri also
has to finish her training with yennefer
but i want to hear what you thought of
the witcher season 2 and your theories
of what could happen in season 3 leave a
comment below thanks for watching
everyone make sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on twitter and instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you